[Music]
i work with dogs to train them to go
into an mri scanner and try to figure
out what makes them tick and what
they're thinking
my name is gregory burns i'm a
neuroscientist at emory university in
atlanta georgia
i've grown up with dogs and i've lived
with dogs pretty much my whole life
one of my favorite dogs had passed away
in the back of my mind i started
wondering did that dog love me in the
way that i loved him and that was really
the beginning of it
all of these basic things that we've
begun to sort out in humans at least in
human brains we want to do in dogs if
dogs can be trained to go into an mri
machine then maybe we could figure out
what they're actually thinking
so we have a dog in the scanner that's
katie and
she is a veteran of the project this is
probably about the 15th time she's done
this
just having the idea of okay well let's
train dogs to go on the scanner it
wasn't immediately apparent how you
would go about doing that and and mri
scanners are
not the most pleasant environments
okay hey cal
coyle good girl callie is the little
black terrier who was the first dog to
train for the dog project
high five i built a simulator of an mri
so this is the simulator that i built
here in my basement then we started
adding in recordings of the scanner
noise which is actually quite loud
we just started working with you know
treats and positive reinforcement to see
if we could get her to go into this
thing
that actually proved to be pretty easy
and then so what we did was we kind of
put out word of mouth do you want to
join this project you want to train your
dogs for an mri and you know maybe
figure out what they're thinking the
purpose of this is to go through a
number of exercises including basic
obedience as well as how they react to
the obstacles
when we hold the tryouts it lets us
weed out the dogs that we don't think
would enjoy doing this
one of the benefits then of having more
participants as it gives you statistical
power you can start to average dogs
brains together and get a better sense
for what's happening
i started wondering very seriously if we
could really finally answer this
question do dogs essentially
like us just for the social bond and not
about the food
and what we found was looking at the
reward system that almost all the dogs
had equal responses both to food as well
as praise and even a few dogs like the
praise more
the things that we were finding about
the dog's brain in many ways confirm i
think what people
know in their hearts about how dogs
behave and why they behave
the way i think about dogs is in many
ways they're the ambassadors to the
animal world
they're not that different from many of
the other mammals out there and so i
suspect that a lot of what we find in
dogs probably holds true for pretty much
any mammal
[Music]
you